wir hatten mal einen halben tag
zivilschutz vortrag ab da ist der
salzburger zivilschutzverband kann man
und der im winter fährt um einen beitrag
leisten konnten
wie viel von dieser woche 5 millionen
klappt sollte irgendwo verrät und
polizei
der hex heutige sitzung geben
sie haben dabei der verklagte ungefähr
1000 also dass die einsatzorganisationen
zu unserem schutz da sein das ist auch
ein unternehmer um wieder zusammensetzen
und mamas aktuelle schau da ist mal die
wurfgewalt auf lag damit man es dunkles
oder gar nix ich das persönlich noch
hand selber seine teile wieder findet
dass man schnell zusammensetzen kann die
augen ja auch diesen versagt
[Musik]
zusammengesetzt am schluss auch noch
nicht ganz den wettbewerb wort und da
hat man schon definitiv merkt dass die
ist richtig auflegen wie vor an geräten
ist definitiv wichtig ist weil sonst
findet dennoch kommen die gar nichts
mehr
[Musik]